what is natural language processing
well you're doing it right now you're
listening to the words and the sentences
that i'm forming
and you are forming some sort of
comprehension
from it and when we ask a computer to do
that
that is nlp on natural language
processing
my name is martin keane i'm a master
inventor at ibm
and i've utilized nlp in a good number
of my invention
disclosures nlp really has a
really high utility value in all sorts
of ai
applications now nlp
starts with something called
unstructured text what is that
well that's just what you and i say
that's how we speak
so for example some unstructured text is
add eggs and milk
to my shopping list
now you and i understand exactly
what that means but it is unstructured
at least
to a computer
so what we need to do is to have a
structured representation of that same
information that a computer can process
now that might look something a bit more
like this where we have a
shopping list element
and then it has sub elements within it
like an
item for eggs
and an item for milk
that is an example of something that is
structured
now the job of natural language
processing
is to translate between these two things
so nlp sits right in
the middle here translating between
unstructured and structured
data and when we go from structure from
unstructured here to structured this way
that's called n l u or
natural language understanding and when
we go this way
from structured to unstructured that's
called natural
language generation or nl
we're going to focus today primarily on
going from unstructured to
structured in natural language
processing
now let's think of some use cases where
nlp
might be quite handy first of all
we've got machine translation
now when we translate from
one language to another we need
to understand the context of
that sentence it's not just a case of
taking each individual word
uh from say english and then translating
it into another language we need to
understand the
the overall structure and and context of
what's being said
and my favorite example of this going
horribly wrong
is if you take the phrase the spirit
is willing but the flesh is weak and you
translate that from english to russian
and then you translate that russian
translation back into english
you're going to go from the spirit is
willing but the flesh
is weak to something a bit more like the
vodka is good
but the meat is rotten which is really
not the intended
context of that sentence whatsoever so
nlp can help
with situations like that now
the the second kind of use case that i
like to mention
relates to virtual assistants
and also to things like chat bots now
a virtual assistant that's something
like siri or alexa
on your phone that is taking human
utterances
and deriving a command to execute based
upon that
and a chatbot is something similar
except in written
language and that's taking written
language and then
using it to traverse a decision tree in
order to take
an action nlp is very helpful there
another use case is for sentiment
analysis now this
is taking some text perhaps an email
message or a product
review and trying to derive the
sentiment that's expressed within it
so for example is this
product review a positive sentiment or a
negative sentiment
is it written as a serious statement
or is it being sarcastic we can use nlp
to tell us and then finally
another good example is spam detection
so this is a case of looking at a given
email message and trying to drive
is this a real email message or is it
spam and we can look for pointers within
the content of the message
so things like overused words or poor
grammar
or an inappropriate claim of urgency can
all
indicate that this is actually perhaps
spam
so those are some of the things that nlp
can provide but
how does it work well the thing with nlp
is it's it's not like one algorithm
it's actually more like a bag of tools
and you can apply these bag of tools
to be able to resolve some of these use
cases
now the input to nlp is some
unstructured text so either some written
text or spoken text that has been
converted to written text
through a speech to text algorithm once
we've got that
the first stage
of nlp is called tokenization
this is about taking a string and
breaking it down into
chunks so if we consider the
unstructured text we've got here
add eggs and milk to my shopping list
that's eight words that can be eight
tokens
and from here on in we are going to work
one token at a time
as we traverse through this now the
first
stage once we've got things down into
tokens that we can perform
is called stemming
and this is all about deriving the word
stem
for a given token so for example running
runs and ran the word stem for all three
of those
is run we're just kind of removing the
prefix and the suffixes and normalizing
the tense and we're getting to the word
stem
but stemming doesn't work well for every
token
for example universal and university
will well they don't really stem down to
universe
for situations like that there is
another tool that we have available
and that is called limitization
and limitization takes a given token and
learns its meaning through a dictionary
definition
and from there it can derive its root or
its
lem so take better for example
better is derived from good so the root
or the
lem of beta is good the
stem of better would be bet
so you can see that it is significant
whether we use
stemming or we use limitization
for a given token
now next thing we can do is we can do
a process called part of speech tagging
and what this is doing is for a given
token
it's looking where that token is used
within the context of
a sentence so take
the word make for example if i
say i'm going to make dinner make
is a verb but if i ask you what make is
your laptop
well make is now a noun so where that
token is used in the sentence
matters part of speech tagging can help
us derive that context
and then finally another stage is
named entity recognition
and what this is asking is for a given
token
is there an entity associated with it so
for example a token of arizona has an
entity of a u.s state whereas
a token of ralph has an entity of
a person's name and these are some of
the tools
that we can apply in this big bag of
tools that we have for nlp
in order to get from this unstructured
human speech through to something
structured that a computer can
understand
and once we've done that then we can
apply that structured data to
all sorts of ai applications now there's
obviously
a lot more to it than this and i've
included some links in the description
if you'd like to know more
but hopefully this made some sense
and that you were able to process
some of the natural language that i've
shared today
thanks for watching if you have
questions please drop us a line below
and
if you want to see more videos like this
in the future please like and subscribe